ウズ
今から日本語の講座を行います
あ今日はへと住民票と所得証明書を1枚ずつください
わかりましたそれでは新生賞を書いていただきますね
まずはここにお名前を
はいそしてここにご住所はいそれからここにお電話番号
はいあここにもお名前を
ご住所はいお電話番号
はいそしてココとココとココお名前ご住所お電話番号を書いてください
はいそれでは最後に印鑑をお願いします
はいありがとうございます
うん感がちょっとずれましたねー
大変申し訳ないんですけれども申請書はもう一枚書いていただけますか
んまずはここに4前をここにお名前の背後住所
はいお電話番号はい国にもお名前をはいご住所
はいお電話番号はいでもう1回ココとココとココ
お前ご住所お電話番号お願いします
はい祝ましたそれでは印鑑をお願いします
ありがとうございます
まさかまぁこれでいいでしょう費用があったです
今もう一枚書くことになるかと思った所得証明書も入りますよねそうですが
ならば申請書もう一枚書いていただきますねまずはここにお名前をお名前をはいご住所
お電話番号
はいどうかされましたかあっあっ飲んでもいいです言っていただいて
結構ですよいやこの過程をもう少し簡単にできないかなーと思ってました
住民が頑張って稼いだお金がこのような効率の悪い作業に費やされているんだと思うと
ちょっと足アクションに対するフィードバックですねああそうですなんか申し訳ないん
ですけどあればフィードバック申請者を書いていただきますね
まずはここにお名前をん
me